bravo
assistance et 17
[Musique]
et non magique
adieu mon rythme
ado
[Musique]
les animaux fantastiques 2 est enfin
sorti et bon sang quel film le
personnage de greendale valdes est
vraiment incroyable
tout comme albus dumbledore on peut
applaudir johnny depp et jude law le
potter games est totalement renversé ce
second opus vient d'apporter de nombreux
éléments et des révélations auxquelles
personne ne s'attendait c'est pourquoi
nous allons essayer de théoriser un max
dans cette vidéo
bien évidemment je vais devoir spoil le
film si je veux être totalement libre
dans mon argumentation
vous êtes prévenus allez il est temps de
s'attaquer de nouveau à cette saga
mythique avec trois théories totalement
personnelle c'est parti
les animaux fantastiques 2 tourne
énormément autour de croyances ce
dernier cherche à découvrir qui il est
réellement qui étaient ses vrais parents
toute l'intrigué du film repose
là-dessus à la base il était supposé que
croyance soit le frère de l'état les
strange disparues et supposées mort
corvus les strange
mais il n'en est rien croyant ce n'est
pas un les strange loin de là et c'est
là que le mystère devient important
grindelwald
à la fin du film affirmé clame haut et
fort que croyance n'est pas n'importe
qui qu'il est le quatrième enfant de la
famille dumbledore et calbuth aurait
tenté de le tuer quand il était encore
qu'un nourrisson
cette révélation chamboule vraiment
toute la saga jusqu'aux origines de
l'histoire
que ce soit dans les livres ou dans les
films kendra et perceval dumbledore
avait trois enfants déjà connues de tous
albus abel forte et ariana alors d'où
sort ce quatrième enfant caché je vais
essayer de répondre à cette question
vous proposant tous les cas de figure
possibles
libre à vous de choisir et croire ceux
qui seraient potentiellement le plus
probable mais j'ai déjà ma petite idée
en tête
est-ce que croyance est réellement
aurelius dumbledore et bien tout laisse
croire que non grindelwald est un très
grand manipulateur et un très grand
sorcier il sait comment parler aux gens
et comment jouer avec eux l'exemple le
plus concret pour moi reste queenie qui
a totalement été séduite par les dires
de grindelwald la sorcière qui
habituellement c'est lire dans les
pensées des gens et les manipuler en
quelque sorte s'est fait avoir par
grindelwald
c'est un détail qui n'est vraiment pas
anodin grindelwald n'est pas n'importe
qui ensuite en liaison avec ce que je
viens de dire nous pouvons enchaîné sur
la question du phénix qui apparaît face
à croyances ceci est l'argument majeur
qui pourrait prouver que croyance est
bel et bien un double-jeu or cependant
ne crions pas victoire trop vite
comme je viens de le dire grindelwald
est un sorcier est un manipulateur très
puissant il est même en possession de la
baguette de sureau ce phénix n'est
peut-être rien de vrai et de réelles
justement retournons sur la scène où
albus est en compagnie de norbert ce
dernier lui affirme qu'une légende dans
sa famille dit qu un phénix apparaîtra
face à chaque membre de la famille
dumbledore néanmoins albus le mentionne
juste ce dernier ne possède toujours pas
de phoenix fume sec ne lui est toujours
pas apparu dans le film
alors pourquoi croyances avant albus
cela reste un détail important
bref je pense qu'il est temps maintenant
de rentrer dans du concret arrêter les
détails
tout d'abord rappelez vous du premier
film des animaux fantastiques
grindelwald avait pris la place de
perceval grails pour se mettre à la
recherche de l'obscur us qui se met le
trouble dans la ville de new york
tout le long du film perceval enfin
greendale valdes penser que l'obscur
yann était modestie et non croyance
alors qu'il le côtoyaient tout le temps
ceci prouve que grindelwald n'avait
jamais connu croyances auparavant qu'il
ne savait pas qui il était vraiment
comment pourrait-il alors connaître ses
origines dans le second opus surtout
qu'apparemment en croyant ce serait un
homme bol d'or
une famille grindelwald a très bien
connu dans son passé pour continuer un
lien très puissant existe entre
grindelwald et albus ces deux derniers
dans leur passé ont effectué un pacte de
sang qui semble aujourd'hui les
empêchait de pouvoir s'affronter
c'est pourquoi norbert travail avec
albus greendale valdes semble employé la
même technique
excepté albus est lui-même seule
croyance semble posséder une puissance
aussi phénoménale et bizarrement
grindelwald lui affirme calbuth avait
tenté de l'assassiner alors qu'il
n'était encore qu'un bébé comme par
hasard bonjour la technique de
manipulation afin de krynn haine envers
albus son rival et sans avoir à faire le
travail lui-même puisque le pacte de
sang est actif d'ailleurs ce pacte de
sang pourrait être liée à la question du
phénix apparu devant croyances
grindelwald connaît très bien les dom
baldor et est encore aujourd'hui
extrêmement liés à al bus par ce pacte
on ne sait pas réellement ce qu'implique
la création d'un pacte de sang entre
deux personnes mais il est peut être
possible que grindelwald possède grâce à
ce dernier une partie de dumbledore en
lui puisque son sang est lié à celui
d'al bus en gros je sais pas si vous
voyez exactement ce que je veux dire
le phénix se pourrait donc être une
simple création de grindelwald et
pourrait même peut-être lui appartenir
mais cela reste une idée un petit peu
folle jeu là vous enfin parlons de date
perceval dumbledore le père de la
famille dumbledore est mort en 1890 et
kendra la mer est quant à elle décédée
en 1899 croyances quant à lui est
apparemment né en 1907 ou 10 908
il est inutile de vous faire un dessin
les dates sont beaucoup trop éloigné
pour que croyance soit le frère caché
d'albus mais alors qui pourrait être
réellement croyances nous n'en savons
rien pour le moment
le phénix qui lui apparaît reste la
seule potentiel preuve qu'il serait un
double-top nous pourrions alors se
tourner vers honoria honoria est une
tante célibataire d'albus dumbledore et
nous ne savons quasiment rien sur l on
suppose qu'elle serait la soeur de
perceval le père d'albus elle serait la
seule clé scénaristique permettant
d'approuver le fait que croyant soit 1 2
build your et peut être même son fils ou
bien peut-être que croyance serait lié à
ariana ces deux derniers sont très
similaires dans leur histoire
ariana et connue de par une théorie très
célèbre le fait qu'elle était auparavant
un obscur yal développant un obscur us
car elle avait refoulé ses pouvoirs
magiques
bref on ne sait pas
mais j'ai une dernière supposition qui
me trotte en tête depuis toujours des
théories circulent sur le fait qu' harry
potter lui même serait le descendant de
godric gryffondor mais pourquoi pas de
croyance croyance n'est vraiment plus un
personnage anodin est l un des plus
puissants sorciers de ce monde
ce dernier pourrait descendre d'un des
fondateurs de poudlard
j'y avais pensé la première fois que
j'ai vu le film je n'ai pas d'argument
pour approuver cette idée a vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez
qui est réellement croyances aurelius
dumbledore
ou est-ce que grindelwald a menti
n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire mais nous sommes
encore loin d'avoir des réponses
[Musique]
parlons maintenant du cadenas guinea et
oui le célèbre serpent qui accompagne le
seigneur des ténèbres est en réalité une
belle jeune femme victime d'un mal et
dictus décrit par jk rowling comme une
malédiction se transmettant de mère en
fille et lié au sang une malédiction qui
transforme petit à petit un humain en
animal jusqu'à devenir véritablement ce
qui est très troublant avec nagini
séquelles et bienveillante envers
croyances notamment elle est une jeune
femme qui a subi beaucoup de malheurs et
de tristesse à cause de sa malédiction
et qui pourtant ne faiblit pas face à
grindelwald et souhaite réellement et
des croyances c'est assez difficile à
imaginer
alors que nous savons que cette dernière
possédera une relation très proche avec
le seigneur des ténèbres dans la saga
harry potter en tant qu serpent pourtant
nagini est un personnage clé des animaux
fantastiques
de par son futur dans la série que
pourrait-elle apporter il est évident
que ces dernières sera présente dans les
autres films de la saga et que son rôle
sera plus important au fil du temps
croyances vient de l'abandonner
poursuivre grindelwald et connaître ses
origines nagini va donc forcément se
joindra à drago nos et toute la clique
pour entrer dans le vif du sujet le
point très important et que nagui n'y ai
énormément lié à voldemort le fait que
son personnage soit présent dans les
animaux fantastiques oblige la présence
de voldemort et donc d'effectuer sa
rencontre avec tom jedusor mais comment
un personnage si bienveillant en quête
de liberté puissent se retrouver à être
le bras droit de voldemort
tout d'abord que savons nous réellement
sur les deux protagonistes brièvement
nagini a été introduit pour la première
fois dans harry potter et la coupe de
feu
elle est celle qui sauva voldemort il
eût permis de survivre
elle l'a ensuite épaulé tout le long de
l'histoire quant à voldemort
anciennement tom jedusor est un enfant
issu d'un philtre d'amour entre une
sorcière de sa mère merope et un maul du
tome qui fut envoûté son père n'est
qu'un géniteur qui ne désirait pas
forcément avoir d'enfant et merope quant
à elle décéda peu après avoir donné
naissance à voldemort
nous savons que tom jedusor a passé le
plus clair de son temps à l'orphelinat
et qu'il arriva à poudlard en 1938 cdn
bol d'or qui est venu à lui afin de le
conduire dans l'école
je pense personnellement qu'il est
obligé que tom est connue nagini quand
elle n'était encore qu'une humaine
d'ailleurs une théorie circule
énormément sur le fait que nagui niçois
la mère de tom elle reste plausible en
effet mais pas tant que ça je trouve
il est vrai que nagini est un pseudonyme
ou du moins pas un véritable nom tout
comme croyance la saga des animaux
fantastiques introduit nagini un an
après la naissance de voldemort en
décembre 1926
si cette dernière meurt quelques temps
après on peut penser au jour où nagini
perdra son enveloppe corporelle humaines
afin de devenir serpent pour toujours
cela expliquerait la relation proche
entre le seigneur des ténèbres et la
jeune femme mais il pourrait que ce soit
tout autre voldemort de 1938 à 1945 soit
la fin de la guerre contre greendale
valdes s'expérimente énormément sur la
magie au point même de cresson première
recrue qs à seulement 16 ans
son journal tom jedusor lors de sa
jeunesse était un grand manipulateur et
ne cherchez pas spécialement à se faire
des amis mais surtout des subordonnés
ils ne voyaient en ses alliés que des
pions tom voit les gens comme un moyen
d'utilisation pour lier ceci on raconte
que justement voldemort a cherché à
contrôler des animaux mais que ces
derniers mourait à chaque fois ne
supportant pas autant de magie noire
si nous revenons à nagui ni un mâle ai
dit tu sais quelque chose de très rare
et dans l'histoire de la guinée nous
savons que cette dernière a permis au
seigneur des ténèbres de survivre grâce
à son venin spéciale de serpents mody sy
voldemort ne voit quand certains qu'une
simple utilité il est possible que c'est
ce qu'il s'est passé avec nagini
voldemort a avait certainement pour but
de trouver un mâle et dictus pour des
pouvoirs un peu spéciaux comme son venin
et donc de la contrôler jusqu'à pourquoi
pas en faire un horcruxe nagini pourra
être possédées par voldemort
nous en avons déjà la preuve avec le
fait que nagini est possédé par
voldemort lors de sa mission secrète au
ministère albus dumbledore affirme
également qu'il est dangereux de faire
d'un autre être vivant un horcruxe car
c'est lui qui en aura le contrôle en
si nagini est contrôlé par voldemort
elle ne peut pas avoir le contrôle sur
elle même l'horcruxe et le fait qu'elle
soit un animal pas comme les autres a
permis au seigneur des ténèbres de la
posséder
d'ailleurs nagini quelqu'un de puissant
sa condition de malé dictus et de
sorcières à lui permettrait donc de
survivre au pouvoir sombre de voldemort
bref plusieurs suppositions peuvent
marcher pour nagini certains supposerait
qu'elle rencontrerait tom jedusor dans
les forêts d'albanie cependant le seul
bémol est que voldemort n'ai jamais eu
réellement besoin de nagini avant qu'il
soit dans un état altéré
nous sommes donc face à un problème au
niveau temporel mais j'ai une dernière
supposition à vous proposer
tom jedusor affirme dans sa jeunesse à
dumbledore qu'il sait parler aux
serpents et qu'ils échangent avec que
voldemort était à l'orphelinat où
roulent en plein coeur de londres en
angleterre
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit un lieu
commun ou les serpents se promènent
peut-être que nagui n'y possède une
relation encore plus profonde que nous
le pensons avec tom jedusor peut être
même qu'elle est un rapport avec
l'orphelinat du jeune seigneur des
ténèbres et peut-être même que c'est
elle qui a guidé albus dumbledore à
l'orphelinat pour trouver tom en tout
cas le mystère est loin d'être résolue
les familles et liaisons dans l'univers
d'harry potter c'est un bazar sont c'est
à se demander comment jk rowling a pu
imaginer tout ça les animaux
fantastiques de nous introduit le
personnage de l'état les strange une
jeune fille très proche de norbert est
fiancée à taizé le frère de ce dernier
l'état et la fille de corvus les strange
4 et de lorna kama sa mère a été victime
du sortilège de limp et riaume lancé par
son père corvus elle possède donc la
même mère que youssouf qui a fait le
voeu incassable de se venger et de tuer
le demi-frère de l'état corps vu ce qui
était supposé être croyances vous avez
déjà vu le bordel que c est bien
attendez ce n'est pas fini
dans l'histoire corvus les strange 5 le
frère de l'état et fils de corvus les
strange 4 est mort noyé
c'est ce qui nous est dit dans le film
l'état avait voulu se séparer de son
frère quand il était bébé pour quelques
heures
car il ne faisait que de pleurer sauf
que cette dernière a échangé les bébés
lors de l'incident en mère et son frère
véritable est alors mort noyé ceci a
créé un traumatisme chez l'état qui en
est même devenu son époux vantard bref
vous connaissez l'histoire corvus était
supposé être croyances mais ce n'était
pas lui
néanmoins la famille les strange a connu
descendance dans l'histoire de l'univers
d'harry potter
le problème c'est que l'état les strange
a été de fait face à grindelwald
certains pensent qu'elle ne l'est pas et
que c'était une mise en scène car elle
est peut-être du côté de grindelwald
pourquoi pas mais s'il ya eu descendance
cela veut donc dire que corvus le frère
de l'état est toujours vivant et qu'il a
survécu à sa pseudo noyade l'état était
simplement fiancée et ne possédez pas
d'enfant après tout la prophétie
concernant yusuf est toujours là et son
voeu incassable également cela voudrait
donc dire que soit l'état soit corvus
ait survécu
en fait nous ne pouvons être sûrs de
rien toute l'histoire concernant la
vengeance de yusuf est beaucoup trop
importante pour que cela s'arrête aussi
simplement aux films 2d animaux
fantastiques
pourquoi introduire corps vu cinq dans
l'histoire s'il n'est pas si important
je sais pas si vous voyez où je veux en
venir
néanmoins les réalisateurs se doit
d'être subtil car scénaristiquement
parlant si nous ne voyons que les films
sur la saga nous pouvons très vite faire
le rapprochement avec bellatrix l'estran
de par le nom de famille donc pour
enrichir l'histoire ils devraient
normalement forcément y avoir un lien
entre les personnages créés par jk
rowling nous savons que bellatrix était
à la base une black et qu'elle est
devenue une les strange par mariage avec
rodolphe us les strange un célèbre
mangemorts du seigneur des ténèbres
mais concernant le père d'euros dollfus
nous ne savons rien il est dit qu
apparemment il serait à la base un
camarade de tom jedusor lors de ses
années à poudlard et qu'il serait né
vers les années 1925 1926 ceci pourrait
peut-être contrecarrer l'idée d'une
potentielle descendance et donc la
survie de soi l'état soit corvus soit en
gros une autre branche familiale des les
strange différente de celle de l'état et
corvus il y aurait donc un problème
temporel et de cohérence pourtant
bizarrement la partie de la famille les
strange dans les années 1910 1920 est
vraiment très peu développé
pile poil la période de l'état et corvus
quelque chose se cache là dessous
l'idée d'une potentielle survie et donc
d'une descendance par la suite
permettrait une bonne cohérence dans la
famille des les strange qui d'ailleurs
ne possède même pas d'arbre généalogique
officiel la famille les strange est un
réel chaos la saga harry potter est une
saga que j'ai aimé que j'ai apprécié
mais les animaux fantastiques me
passionne et me donne encore plus envie
de m'intéresser à l'univers
tout ce que je viens de vous énoncez
n'est que théorique bien sûr et
d'ailleurs mes respects à jk rowling
pour avoir créer et garder des mystères
pendant plus de 20 ans je suis heureux
d'avoir rendu hommage à la séance
bref j'espère que la vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleus à vous abonner et à me laisser un
petit commentaire je veux voir vos avis
vous pouvez également me suivre sur
twitter me soutenir financièrement sur
uts iep aller c'était argot rock et que
le 'lion' woerth soit avec vous
[Musique]